Je me faisais constamment taquiner par tout le monde,
surtout ma grande sœur et mon grand frère.
Quand j'ai perdu ma dent de devant,
mon frère m'a regardée et m'a dit :
« Ah, ça t'es arrivé à toi aussi ?
Elle ne repoussera pas. »
(Rires)
Je jouais partout,
surtout dans le jardin de ma mère et de mes voisins.
J'adorais mon école.
On y chantait des chansons,
on jouait partout
et on prenait notre déjeuner.
J'ai passé une enfance
que je souhaite à tous.
Mais lorsque j'ai eu six ans,
les adultes de ma famille ont commencé à chuchoter,
et me faisait taire lorsque je posais des questions.
Une nuit,
mes parents sont venus nous voir.
Ils avaient une expression étrange quand ils nous ont réveillés.
Ils nous ont envoyées, ma grande sœur Claire et moi, chez nos grands-parents,
espérant que ce qui était en train de se passer finirait par se tasser.
Peu de temps après, nous fuirons cette maison aussi.
On se cachait,
on rampait,
on courait parfois.
Parfois j'entendais un rire,
puis un cri et des pleurs,
et ensuite des bruits que je n'avais jamais entendus auparavant.
Vous voyez,
je ne comprenais pas
ce qu'étaient ces bruits.
Ils n'étaient pas humains,
et même temps, ils l'étaient.
Je voyais des gens qui ne respiraient plus,
je pensais qu'ils dormaient.
Je ne comprenais pas encore ce qu'était la mort,
ou le meurtre en lui-même.
Quand on s'arrêtait pour se reposer un instant
ou pour chercher à manger,
je fermais les yeux,
espérant qu'en les rouvrant,
je me réveillerais.
Je n'avais aucune idée où était ma maison.
Le jour, on se cachait,
la nuit, on marchait.
Après avoir dû fuir notre foyer,
nous l'avons totalement perdu.
L'endroit qui est censé vous accueillir
vous a rejeté,
et personne ne veut vous accueillir.
Vous êtes rejeté
par tous.
Vous êtes un réfugié.
Entre six et douze ans,
j'ai vécu dans sept pays différents,
me déplaçant d'un camp de réfugiés à un autre,
en espérant être accueillie.
Ma grande sœur Claire
est devenue une jeune mère...
et une pro pour faire avancer les choses.
Quand j'avais 12 ans,
je suis arrivée aux Etats-Unis avec Claire et sa famille avec le statut de réfugiés.
Et ce n'était qu'un début,
parce que même si j'avais 12 ans,
j'avais parfois l'impression d'en avoir 3,
et parfois 50.
Mon passé s'estompait,
devenait flou,
déformé.
Tout devenait trop
et rien à la fois.
Le temps ressemblait aux pages déchirées d'un livre
et semées un peu partout.
J'ai encore cette impression en ce moment même.
Après notre arrivée en Amérique,
Claire et moi n'avons jamais parlé de notre passé.
En 2006,
après 12 années passées
séparée de ma famille,
et après 7 ans passées à les croire morts
et eux à croire que nous étions mortes,
nous nous sommes retrouvés...
de la façon la plus dramatique et la plus américaine possible.
En direct,
à la télévision,
(Rires)
pendant l'émission d'Oprah Winfrey.
(Applaudissements)
Je vous l'avais bien dit.
(Rires)
Mais après l'émission,
alors que je passais du temps avec mon père, ma mère
ma petite sœur,
et mes deux nouveaux frères et sœurs que je n'avais jamais rencontrés,
j'ai ressenti de la colère.
J'ai ressenti une peine profonde en moi.
Et je sais qu'il n'y a absolument rien,
rien,
qui pourrait restaurer le temps que nous avons perdu les uns avec les autres,
ni les relations que nous aurions pu avoir.
Bientôt, mes parents déménagèrent aux États-Unis,
mais comme Claire,
ils ne parlent jamais de notre passé.
Ils vivent dans un présent perpétuel.
Ils ne se posent pas trop de questions,
ne s'autorisent pas à ressentir...
ils avancent à petits pas.
Aucun d'entre nous n'arrive évidemment à comprendre ce qui nous est arrivé.
Bien que ma famille soit en vie,
nos vies se sont bel et bien brisées,
et oui, nous sommes paralysés
et réduits au silence par notre propre expérience.
Ce n'est pas seulement le cas de ma famille.
Le Rwanda n'est pas le seul pays au monde
où les gens se sont retournés les uns contre les autres
et se sont entretués.
Tous les hommes,
de bien des façons,
ressemblent à ma famille.
Pas morts,
mais brisés, paralysés et rendus muets par la violence du monde
qui a pris le contrôle.
Voyez-vous,
le chaos de la violence continue à l'intérieur,
dans les mots que nous utilisons,
et les histoires que nous inventons chaque jour.
Mais aussi à cause des étiquettes que nous imposons à nous-mêmes
et aux autres.
Une fois que l'on a nommé quelqu'un « autre »,
« moins que »,
« l'un d'eux »,
ou « meilleur que »,
croyez-moi...
avec les conditions adéquates,
c'est un court chemin vers plus de destruction.
Plus de chaos,
et plus de bruit
que nous ne comprendrons pas.
Les mots ne suffiront jamais
pour quantifier et qualifier les différentes ampleurs
de la destruction que peut causer l'Homme.
Afin que nous
mettions un terme à la violence qui sévit dans le monde,
j'espère...
ou du moins je vous supplie...
de faire une pause.
Demandons-nous :
qui sommes-nous sans les mots ?
Qui sommes-nous sans les étiquettes ?
Qui sommes-nous dans notre souffle ?
Qui sommes-nous dans notre cœur ?
(Applaudissements)